[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la réception à l'Elysée par le général
de Gaulle des délégués à la conférence
de l'OTASE l'alliance occidentale en
Asie a souligné l'harmonie des relations
de la France et des pays anglo-saxons
[Musique]
présence commune à l'OTAN à la réunion
hebdomadaire du Conseil permanent de
Messieurs dinrusk Couve de Murville et
Lord yum a mis en évidence l'importance
des problèmes qui ont été évoqués au
cours des trois journées diplomatiques
dont Paris a été le théâtre
Buenos Aires le calme règne après
l'orage l'orage c'est-à-dire la révolte
militaire manquée qui durant deux jours
à plonger l'Argentine dans le désordre
la rébellion avait été déclenchée par
des forces de la marine dont les chefs
espèrent ainsi empêcher les prochaines
élections et avec elle un éventuel
succès péroniste
les troupes fidèles au président de la
République Roger Maria Guido était
parvenu au prix de combat de rue
relativement violent à s'assurer le
contrôle de la capitale
[Musique]
mais en d'autres points à magdalenya
notamment la lutte avait été beaucoup
plus indécis
malgré l'intervention des avions
rebelles les soldats loyalistes
enlevaient pendant la décision
quant à la base navale de Pinto Indio
aux mains des rebelles elle fut le
théâtre de combat furieux lorsque les
forces gouvernementales par 20 à y
pénétrer l'état des lieux en disait long
sur la bataille
[Musique]
de nouvelles plaies à penser pour
l'Argentine
lancez voici moi de deux ans le très
cher premier des sous-marins d'assaut
américain a propulsion nucléaire était
considéré comme saint rival quant à la
vitesse et au rayons de plongée deux
bâtiments du même type ont été
construits on doit en construire encore
19 la disparition du très cher par 2500
mètres de fond avec 129 hommes à bord
constitue la plus grande catastrophe
sous-marine connue à ce jour
[Musique]
la circulation parisienne est sans doute
une rue d'école pour les apprentis
conducteurs on ne pose pendant pas dire
qu'elle favorise beaucoup leur
tranquillité d'esprit face aux problèmes
épineux du changement de vitesse et au
milieu des appréciations généralement
peu flatteuses des automobilistes
confirmés
[Musique]
aussi convient-il d'apprécier
l'initiative qui a abouti à la création
en saône-et-oise d'un circuit spécial où
les candidats à la maîtrise du volant
pourront désormais évoluer entre eux et
dans les conditions même de la
circulation normale
aussitôt a pris les premiers rudiments
l'élève est lâchée seule dans sa voiture
sous la surveillance discrète cependant
du moniteur prêt à intervenir en cas de
faute grave
[Musique]
progressivement on finira par faire du
débutant plus qu'un honnête conducteur
un véritable pilote
et capable de circuler en virtuose et en
triple files coincé entre deux voitures
dans les rues de Paris à 7 heures du
soir
[Musique]
c'est un sport qui fait fureur sur les
pentes du parc national de Vannes au
Canada une paire de ski un club de golf
une balle et un parcours de 9 trous
voilà le score le ski gold
il requiert d'une part une technique
éprouvée dans l'une et l'autre de ses
disciplines et d'autres parts un profond
mépris du ridicule
à vrai dire les règles de cet arrêt
brides semblent assez libéral on peut
craindre d'autres mariages de des
raisons au sein de la grande famille des
Sports à quand le rugby en kayak ou la
lutte bretonne à bicyclette
[Musique]
le motocross est demeurer fidèle en
Europe à ces audaces éprouvées on l'a
bien vu en Espagne où il a mis aux
prises des machines de 250 cm3
parcours tourmenté à Suède ou ses
fougueuses ruades et ses spectaculaires
envolés qui ne sont pas sans rappeler
les plus audacieuses des charges de
cavalerie
autre lieu autre technique en URSS un
bandage clouté comme une planche de
Fakir permet aux machines de tenir sur
une piste de glace ce qui autorise ces
virages incroyablement couchés qui
semblent un défi aux lois de l'équilibre
un sport qui fait fureur près du cercle
polaire
sur le stade liberté à Dakar ouverture
solennel des jeux de l'amitié en
présence du président Léopold Senghor et
de 25000 spectateurs enthousiastes
[Musique]
après cananari et Abidjan la troisième
édition des Jeux réunis les délégations
des pays et territoires francophones du
monde entier auxquels se sont joints
cette année plusieurs pays africains
d'expression anglaise au total près de
3000 athlètes qui dans les stades et sur
les pistes de la capitale sénégalaise
vont lutter pacifiquement pendant 10
jours dans une confrontation amicale et
désintéressée
[Musique]
c'est l'athlète pierre William qui a
prêté le serment solennel au nom des
participants à cette version africaine
des Olympiades
si les demeurées en Suisse le fleuve
tumultueux qu'il était jadis né des
glaces et des neiges des Alpes leur un
par contre n'est plus aujourd'hui le
même qu'autrefois quand il aborde la
plaine d'Alsace dès 1928 l'homme a
entrepris domestiquer son cours inégal
et dangereux en le doublant d'un canal
latéral
[Musique]
auteur du barrage de Kembs le Grand
Canal d'Alsace commençait d'assumer sa
double mission rendre le cours du Rhin à
la navigation et alimenter la centrale
électrique dont les six turbines
travaillent sous 14 mètres de chute
après la guerre depuis 1948 tous les
trois ans une nouvelle centrale s'est
dressée sur le cours du fleuve
Ottmarsheim près de Mulhouse
[Applaudissements]
la troisième de cette suite d'usine
neuve qui jalonne la partie française du
cours du Rhin de bal à Strasbourg
déserté au début du siècle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la centrale de foggle Green a lit la
perfection technique à l'équilibre
esthétique de l'ensemble
le moins surprenant n'est sans doute pas
le décor intérieur conçu pour le plaisir
des yeux qui humanise la salle des
machines
à Marckolsheim la dernière née des
centrales du Rhin l'art est également
mis au service de la technique et de
l'efficacité
en aval les travaux se poursuivent
l'usine de Rina se construit à sec et
lorsqu'elle se rend achevées les
centrales hydroélectriques du rein
fourniront 7 milliards de kilowatts
heure par an le dixième de la production
française actuelle
en même temps le Grand Canal d'Alsace
s'achève des engins mécaniques puissants
tracent les berges de la nouvelle voie
d'eau plus large dans tout son cours que
le canal de Suez
avec son complément alsacien façonné de
la main de l'homme le vieux Rhin des
bourges romantiques pourra demain
assumer dans toute sa plénitude
s'attache ancestrale qui est d'être la
grande voie de communication économique
la grande artère internationale
indispensable aux échanges européens
[Musique]